quand l'état monsieur céleste lett le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
ce premier ministre votre texte sur le
travail se voulait au départ
révolutionnaire et ambitieux permettant
enfin aux entreprises de s'organiser
plus simplement aujourd'hui après moult
chamboulement pour faire plaisir aux uns
et aux autres il n'est plus qu'un simple
projet rétrograde vidé de toute
substance démonstration sarreguemines ma
ville compte deux grandes entreprises
allemandes continental moins de 2000
salariés et la smart plus de 2000
salariés toutes les deux confronté à des
objectifs de compétitivité ont formulé
le voeu de sauver ces milliers d'emplois
en contrepartie d'efforts à réaliser sur
le coût et le temps de travail
dernièrement la modification provisoire
de la durée du travail chez smart
approuvée par plus de 56 % des salariés
interrogés par référendum s'est heurtée
vous le savez à un refus catégorique de
deux syndicats bien moins représentatifs
dans un territoire voisin de l'allemagne
où grâce à un syndicalisme fort et plus
représentatif existe un véritable
dialogue social
le message adressé par nos organisations
syndicales haut responsable allemand est
catastrophique
heureusement le droit d'opposition
n'aura pas eu raison de choix sans appel
d'une très large majorité de salariés
qui avec pas moins de 97 % d'avenant
signé on éviter la délocalisation en
slovénie je vous remercie d'ailleurs
monsieur prémices de lait coûte que vous
m'aviez à l'époque apporter jeu premier
ministre votre texte initial c'est en
prévoir des avancées significatives
aujourd'hui vous reculez j'ai peur que
demain d'autres belles entreprises
subissent les mauvaises orientations
prises par une minorité non
représentative donner la priorité à
l'emploi et conforter la parole des
salariés
cela ne doit pas apparaître comme un
contournement de la voie syndicale
au contraire ce n'est ni plus ni moins
qu'un bel exemple de démocratie
participative précis la parole est à
madame myriam elle comme rémy
travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue ce
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
céleste lett
il y à un changement majeur en effet
dans ce projet loi c'est une plus grande
place laissée à la négociation
collective parce que nous pensons en
effet que dans notre pays aujourd'hui
notre système est venu à bout de souffle
et que si ce code du travail est devenu
à juste titre de plus en plus épais
c'est bien parce qu'il ya eu de
nombreuses dérogations ont été demandés
d'ailleurs par les organisations
patronales et qui vise à couvrir toutes
les situations et que nous voyons bien
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes passés dans
une ère un peu d'industriels à une aire
de service et que nous pourrons pas
couvrir tout le champ d adaptation c'est
pour cela que ce projet de loi c'est un
acte de confiance en direction des chefs
d'entreprise est un acte de confiance en
direction des syndicats
tout l'enjeu de ce projet de loi c'est
de laisser plus de capacité d'adaptation
au plus près de terrain et de ce point
de vue là nous n'avons absolument pas
changé la philosophie de ce projet de
loi nous confortons les organisations
syndicales en effet mais nous
élargissons les objets de la négociation
ou les allergies sont parce que
l'exemple par exemple que vous donnez de
smart
c'est un exemple dialogue social n'a pas
été exemplaire et que finalement
qu'est-ce que a conduit cette affaire ce
matin a fait que ce sont les salariés
qui se sont retrouvés dans une relation
déséquilibrée avec l'employeur à devoir
modifier les contrats de travail
c'est ce que nous ne souhaitons pas nous
souhaitons qu'avec des accords
collectifs majoritaire nous puissions
apporter avec une équation simple pas de
souplesse en négociation et puisque les
entreprises veulent de la souplesse
il y aura de la négociation avec ce
projet loi il y a deux modalités de mise
en oeuvre de ces accords le premier
c'est un accord majoritaire en effet
pour renforcer la légitimité accord à
partir du moment où nous ouvre l'objet
des négociations et le second c'est de
permettre à des organisations syndicales
qui représentent 30% des voix de pouvoir
en effet demandé une consultation des
salariés
hélas nous ne sommes pas dans le
contournement des organisations
syndicales
monsieur le député croyez-moi ce projet
loi répond véritablement aux demandes
qui sont formulées à la fois par les
salariés mais également et rachid
hamdami nice la parole est à mme